so it's a day that tennis and everybody
has been dreading the end of roger
federer's tennis career and roger i've
covered a lot of retirements and there's
always a lot of tears but you seem quite
at peace with your decision how hard was
it to make how did you make it
there were tears of course you know when
i let my uh
friends and family or my my friends know
or when they ultimately also the
decision was taken with the team that i
think uh we've come to the to the end of
it all you know and it's been
a wonderful moment uh you look back at
all the
the great things we have achieved
together and that it's okay to step away
you know and uh
have others uh do their magic you know
on a tennis court and not maybe me so
much anymore
on the tour and everything so
it's been hard you know of course but i
could see it also coming the last few
years it's been not easy
playing so little rehabbing all the time
and
coming to the realization um was only
about logical for me also at some point
so i am really much at peace like you
said
how special is it to finish here in
london with your your greatest rivals
all around you on the same team and
maybe your greatest rival rafa maybe
you'll even get to play with him how
special is it to finish here or did you
just plan that
in the perfect way that you tend to do
things no no i really try not to over
plan this one um because i always said
we'll deal with retirement when it
actually happens and then once i decided
internally that this was it i actually
went on vacation for
god knows how long and i didn't even
think about it i didn't want to talk
about it with mirka we didn't
uh really plan it all out or anything
and only when i got back uh
um my agent tony was uh thinking you
need to let me know if it's gonna be the
labor cup or not uh at least i can
organize something for you or not let me
know and uh because i wasn't sure if i
should maybe announce it before the us
open but then i was not going to be
there
so i really didn't know what to do and
when i announced it on thursday i had
nothing planned for
you know friday saturday sunday monday
also out of respect
for the queen's funeral coming up and i
just said well let's just see how it all
plays out at least it gives some people
um advanced notice before the labor cup
that i was going to be here and it gives
me a chance at the labor cup to see the
the crowd see the fans be surrounded by
um
by all the greatest players and uh have
a great time and have fun because that's
what i wanted to be
first of all serena
now you
it is the end of an era what have you
both brought to the sport do you think
different things for sure you know but
at the end we both did it as moms and
dads you know
funny to think think of that because uh
both when we were young made it on tour
and never thought we're probably going
to end as
as that at the end um i think we were
definitely the bridge you know for a
very long time from the old generation
to the new generation which i think
has been a privilege for me to play
across generations like this same for
her um
and she brought the power game in like
no other so she's been obviously
instrumental with that and being um a
game changer is something um
that i think
is the ultimate compliment i don't know
if i did that in any way but i did it my
way and i i hope people enjoy watching
me play for so long and
i know we'll always would love to return
to tennis in some shape or form but i
don't know in which capacity but i loved
my my life on tour and i can't thank
the people enough for all their support
throughout the years